mmm my own oh yeah yeah that works
little louder actually is it too loud we
might paint at me we might be dealing do
old all right but that's okay hopefully
this is loud enough how's that it'll do
I'll be off in a minute anyway
hey Gary nice to you
so that clock correct we get started
1130 welcome everybody my name is Aaron
Cohen i'm professor and department
medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology i know many of you but not
all of you so welcome this is our
regular Thursday conference some
Thursday conferences we designate as an
IDL conference my mic is suckling a
little bit which the IDL is the
informatics discovery lab which is sort
of an outreach collaboration initiative
within the department and we bring in
illuminaries from various industry
positions to educate us on what's going
on in the real world of informatics so
today we have one of those luminaries
dr. richard gibson who is a well-known
colleague and friend of the department
before i get into the bio i'm just going
to say a couple of things i guess this
is some talk is available for CME credit
and anybody who needs to get CME credit
please email lynn schwabe and she will
give you the details but they can't take
some kind of online test and she'll do
that also we are streaming and recording
so if you have any questions or comments
during a Q&A period please press the
little button on the black box in front
of you so the light goes on so it gets
recorded in strength okay anything else
logistical I need to say that i forgot i
don't think so okay so dr. richard
gibson is our guest today dr. richard
gibson md PhD is currently the executive
director of the health record banking
alliance and he's going to be talking
about that today which is a nonprofit
organization founded in 2006 to promote
consumer centered consumer controlled
comprehensive lifetime medical records
dr. Gibson comes to us to from health
record banking alliance previously to
that he was in a position at Gartner Inc
where he was the research director and
previously he's held roses chief
intelligence healthcare intelligence
officer at providence health and
services chief information officer at
legacy health and chief medical officer
at providence health systems for the
oregon region he's an affiliate
assistant
so in the department of medical
informatics and clinical epidemiology at
ohsu his educational background includes
a bachelor's science from Stanford and
MD from case western reserve a PhD in
medical informatics from the University
of Utah fellowship in Intermountain
Healthcare in salt lake city and an MBA
from the Wharton School he's also that
wasn't enough a retired family physician
an emergency physician and I had to read
all this because there's no way I could
remember all that stuff so today doctor
gives know people talk to us about
health record banks and how complete
data can lead to a better patient care
and I am very interested to see what he
says up to these days with that okay
thank you thank you thank you for
joining us so I was scheduled on
december nine thursday to give you a
talk on population health management
really good talk but I've got snowed out
then and then lapsed on I'm thinking oh
maybe a groundhog day all over again for
this talk but we're good and we'll get
you out in time to avoid snowmageddon
here in Portland so ah no no disclosures
to make to the audience and in 1984 I
finish my family medicine residency in
Spokane and I owed the National Health
Service a couple of years because they
paid for a couple years of my medical
school and so I move to forks Washington
and when I came out to Fort switch about
five hours north of here I was starting
a new private family practice there and
one of the doctors was retiring and so I
met him on Main Street where his office
was and he says on when I have a patient
referred to you I said oh yeah and it's
a young woman who's pregnant so happy to
see her could I get a records and so he
walks over to his death and brings back
a five by eight card and this is just a
facsimile so this is not real patient
data and on the front it had her
birthday her own birthday date and her
birth weight and then a set of visits
all on one line and then he flipped it
over and again more visits through her
adolescent years and positive pregnancy
test referred to dr. Getz 1984 once you
love to go back to those days I think
it's ironic that I spent most of my
career dealing with electronic health
records and now I would not say that
electronic
records are in the beloved state that
such a card was for some doctors back in
nineteen eighty-four but I do think that
there's hope to get back to that easier
state with the electronic record is not
thought thing in front of you in the
exam room but supports your care and I
think that health record banks are part
of that so what we'll talk about today
is the general setting for why we're
using data and healthcare all known to
you we'll talk about I'll review current
status of health information exchanges
lightly just to provide context for
health record banks will go into health
record banks will talk about a proposed
business model we'll talk about
blockchain just to slide on blockchain
because they get to have so often and
then we'll wrap up so that the challenge
we have with health records is that if
you're in the inpatient setting like an
ohsu the patient has a complete record
and not a challenge journey things
everything that's happened to them at a
weight issue and of course would care
everywhere you can see everything that's
happened in an epic facility across the
country again at ohsu outpatient you
have the same issue but for most of the
care in America especially in the
ambulatory environment doctors are
progressing was only a part of the
records that the patients have
accumulated over their lifetime and so
the problem is that we get under
treatment over treatment and treatment
with errors so Asher script survey
showed that fifty-five percent of care
was missing a complete history and that
forty-nine percent of the time patients
said that the doctor didn't even know
what prescriptions they were on now that
wouldn't apply to ohsu but we have a
problem bigger than the challenge at
only tissue so the case we're making
that we need comprehensive care at the
time of care in order to give good care
to do quality to do policymaking and to
understand what we're doing for our
patients that means that a care has to
be electronic to begin with so doctor is
already on electronic health records so
that's good and the challenges now we
have scattered information over each
electronic health record of
consternation about how to get that
information from the scattered hie spots
to the place where the patient happens
to be right now and oh by the way we
also have dental records to do and we
have home care
and other kinds of interactions that
people have with providers that need to
be brought in as well we already have
digital health care we have common
standards and we need to find a place to
pull it all together one of the
challenges no mystery to you all is that
we need care we need electronic health
records for care at the point of care
where they need to be immediate and need
to have a rapid response time and we
also need retrospective analysis care
again for policymaking for quality
analysis for population health
management for understanding our
outcomes and what works best now that
requires that you get all the records
together but it doesn't need immediate
response time and you can vary even can
be a delay and we'll talk about that why
are we where we are well of course again
no mr. to you all there's been a medical
explosion in terms of data and
specialties which means any given
problem requires you to see more than
one provider so that you have scattered
records no individual brighter tend to
have all their records unless you've
gotten all your care at a given facility
so there's an opportunity to manage
records better we know that we need to
engage patients and population health
that we're going to get the best
outcomes they need be motivated take
care of themselves and be given the
tools to do that and smartphones will
play into this so 564 million dollars of
the federal money spent starting 2010 to
build state health information exchanges
and HHS weighed in in 2013 said more
will be needed and many of the hie s
have already failed but some are working
and we'll review some of those so the
challenge is to help information
exchanges is that there's an issue of
trust in fact a lot of the time is spent
with the attorneys building a
distributed rights agreement to examine
each other's data and make sure that the
patients are on board with that and that
requires a lot of stakeholder agreements
that are hard to come by once you have
it it works pretty well there's always
been a problem with sustainability I
just reviewed a book on interoperability
just not a lot to say about
sustainability what works and what's
required and that we know that health
information
are expensive it requires a lot of
coordination on IT a lot of 24 by 7
monitoring pretty challenging stuff we
believe that the focus on health
information exchange pulling together
distributed data is the wrong approach
and that what we're trying to do is to
repeat what goes on in the paper world
so provider I mean a patient comes to
see a clinician with his or her
electronic health record and right now
with hie the idea is you go to the index
and say where are the records stored you
go out to each of those stores and you
pull it back you assemble it you bring
it back to the clinician who then sees
the patient and puts the data back in
the HR and a cycle goes through the
problems are that it's real time record
reconciliation you get multiple records
come in at the same time and you have to
avoid overwhelming clinician with too
many duplicate data points and that's
hard to do it also works best with a
patient identifier nationally of course
which we don't have there's always the
challenge that you're going to miss data
and you won't collect the full group of
data you also have a problem with the
data coming from the electronic health
records being assembled and then moved
on to the provider so for each data
element it's being transmitted twice
which means this is more of a security
risk searching for research is more
difficult because you have a distributed
model and that so far we haven't found a
new broadly applicable way to make this
sustainable now this was a simulation
paper where they put in a failure rate
of being able to collect data from a
node a node would be electronic health
record of an office or a hospital that
sort of thing and they set that at
various levels but for this chart it's
at failing five out of ten thousand
that's a ninety-nine point nine five
percent success rate most would say
that's pretty good for retrieving it
then they looked at well how many times
would a patient be seen in a year and
then how many providers is typical for
patients to see in a given year nessa
get older of course that number can go 7
10 and above so what they showed was in
simulation that you're going to have a
lot more failures when you have a
distributed model then
when you have a centralized model where
all the data are in one place now the
next case domini well why don't we just
work where there's not all the data well
Billy as mob who founded the health
record bank proposed and wrote about it
that really with electronic health
records just having only half the
medication list probably does it make it
worthwhile in order to take the trouble
to health information exchange you have
to be reasonably assured did you have
most of the data before those data and
effort to get to it becomes worthwhile
again an argument for putting all the
data in one place so that one of the
challenges of many in health information
exchanges is that if a patient's going
to record that they have concerns about
their privacy or they have requests for
it they're going to have to register
that each organization across the
country that has their record and then
there's a chance that they forgot one or
that they have to update it they have to
go back and update them all because this
is being pulled from each of those
sources at the time that the patient
seen at their next provider the
challenge with annotated data or
correcting data that's difficult when
you have a distributed model so they can
get back to age issue and correct
problems that they see on the ohsu my
chart or equivalent but it's hard doing
that across the country and then you
don't propagate the corrections although
the next time they pull from you your
record will send the correct record to
that clinician across the state across
the country right now mostly
participation health information
exchange is voluntary and it's
troublesome they doctors have to pay
interface costs and these are reasons
why you don't get full participation
some places around the country house but
it's not widespread so I'm just going to
review graphically some of those things
that we know about health information
exchange currently and this is the
following slides are about a review done
and turned in March of 2016 about the
state health information exchange and
now of course their private health
information exchanges whose data may
only be partially represented on this
chart but the idea here is that
this is turned in 2016 directed exchange
you can see that most states have
directors name that means direct trust
that means like a secure email we have
clinicians secure address and you send a
note as needed or when we crossed it so
most states have that interesting not
I'd oh but then when we look at curry
base exchange so the eHealth exchange or
Sequoia or carry quality or common well
then it's a it's a little different not
so many place to that you see Oregon
doesn't have a widespread query-based
change except what we have with epic now
this is looking at acute care hospitals
participating in health information
exchange so according to American
Hospital Association the 54 acute care
hospital four hundred Q care hospitals
the United States doing about 37 million
hospitalization and you can see the
number of hospitals doing some kind of
health informatics change has come up
dramatically since these programs are
put in place starting in 2011 but you
still see that only about 2,100 hostels
out of 5400 through 2013 were
participating in health information
exchange and most of that was query and
all bench a lot of that is epic doing
query to other epic facilities so the
the dark blue is directed exchange the
light blue is query now when we go to
ambulatory facilities the situation
reverses its still dramatically
increasing good for that 23 230,000
physician offices 15,000 urgent care
centers 925 million patient visits a
year ambulatory and you see directed in
the case of physician office way
outweighs query and it's nice to see
that going up but we still only have
thirty thousand offices out of 245,000
sites participating so we're still a
long way away from having a sort of
coverage we need and again the details
here aren't important well the dark blue
represents 80 to 100 percent and we're
talking about hospitals exchanging
clinical care summary tears 2011 years
2014 well look at that look who's at the
top of the heat for exchanging clinic
here at summaries Washington Oregon now
and kudos to us for getting that done
we're doing a good job with that i
tribute a lot of that the concordance
around epic but it's still a good job by
our state's and our clinicians to get
that done now this is part out same
report looking at how do you evaluate
cumulatively health information exchange
and what they've chosen to do is what
they've chosen to do is say it can be
represented by seven different
facilities hospitals exchanging clinical
care summaries with ambulatory providers
and so and the dark blue was what was
the case in 2010 and that light gray is
2014 so you can see a dramatic
improvement that sixty-six percent of
hospitals now exchange clinical care
summaries with ambulatory providers not
all ambulatory providers it's just that
they do do it and then the next one is
exchanging clinical care summaries with
other hospitals again about sixty
percent not bad I'm choosing not to
focus on lab results both showing
results and viewing results ambulatory
and ordering lab orders and viewing
resorts that's kind of old style here
for organ we did that a long time ago
mostly and physicians prescribing
e-prescribing chr i think that the
clinical summaries is really what we're
talking about that has the core part of
the data that are crucial for informing
care both real-time and in analysis now
this chart is about the dark blue is
here it's the hospital to use health
information exchange and those that use
of meaningful use certified electronic
health record so you see ninety-five
percent of hospitals use meaningful use
certified EHRs seventy-six percent of
hospitals engage in health information
exchange here's the same thing for
physician offices seventy-eight percent
are using certified electronic health
records but only thirty-eight percent
using health information exchange still
not bad I mean thirty-eight percent but
look at the number of patient visits
according to this study number of
patient visits in
we're health information exchange data
was available at the visit so the unit
analysis of the visit were way way
behind in terms of providing data for
care so we've done a good job with
health information exchange but we have
a long way to go and I would propose
we're not on the right track so we have
distributed architecture that we've been
talking about the information is left in
place at each provider organization you
get it when you need it it's inefficient
it has its error-prone it doesn't scale
it's harder to protect privacy it's
impractical to search for research or
application processes in a centralized
architecture the ideas should bring it
together in one place in one account
like a bank account and that the
comprehensive records over time as
they're collected are then available to
the next provider so health record banks
the concepts been around for a long time
near list one that we know about was
written about it was Peter Sullivan's
from MIT talking about the guardian
angel it has a long paper talking about
that value that health record banks or
the equivalent can bring to the process
of care Jonathan gold Marion ball wrote
a paper in 2007 for the IBM systems
journal Marion balls been a big advocate
of this for a long time it's a secure
repository of health records that
patient or consumer decides who gets to
look at the record and for how long and
is aware of everybody who does look at
their records I think that idea the
metaphor of a bank makes sense the idea
of we know most of us don't keep all our
money on our person in our house we
trust somebody like a bank which are
mostly trustable notwithstanding the
recent problems at Wells Fargo but
that's that's just leadership and you
still add 100,000 employees are doing a
great job I'd say banks are generally
trustful and that the idea is you
collect deposits like your financial
pauses put them in a place and then you
direct how they spend you don't just go
to wells fargo and say we'll just buy
whatever you think i need you say i want
you to send that amazon that's a weight
issue that to the valet whatever it is
we're doing the same thing with your
data now HIPAA is clear although I would
say most providers don't know that let's
read what it says about the individual
we're an individual request and
electronic copy of protected health
information
that a covered entity maintains
electronically which is pretty common
health course the covered entity must
provide the individual with access to
the information in the requested
electronic form and format if it is
readily producible in that form and
format in terms of a designated Krusty
HIPAA goes on to say and individual also
has a right to direct the covered entity
to transmit the protected health
information about the individual
directly to another person or entity
designated by the individual pretty
clear but that's the sort of thing
they're talking about 21st century cures
past December 2016 also confirms their
intention of a single longitudinal
record section 4006 of this 996 page
bill says the Secretary shall use
existing authorities to encourage
partnerships between health information
exchange organizations and networks and
healthcare providers health plans and
other appropriate entities with the goal
of offering patients access to their
electronic health information a single
longitudinal format that is easy to
understand secure and may be updated
automatically they go on the secretary
that means secretary of health and human
services in consultation with the
National Coordinator shall promote
policies that ensure that a patient's
electronic health information is
accessible to that patient and the
patient's designee in a manner that
facilitates communication with the
patient's health care providers and
other individuals including researchers
consistent with such patients consent so
I think the the intent of both laws is
clear although I would say that most
individual providers are unaware of how
in how purposeful this is and what
demand if a patient walked in could put
on the practice these are our principles
of our alliance each patient's records
should be functionally stored in one
place but not all records in the same
place I'll come back to that each
patient should control access to his or
her own medical records medical records
should be stored under patient
controlled by a trusted organization
there was an article in The Wall Street
you know a couple weeks ago that talked
about patients during all the records on
their mobile phone as if they could go
around and collect it maybe that will
come about someday but it puts the onus
on individuals we think with the health
record
thank you don't personally have to ferry
check among the payment sources we think
that you're going to get a trust or
organization to collect your data too so
I think was a little misguided in that
wall street journal but we'll get back
for that so with the centralized model
the clinician looks up the patient's
records if it's to get the update the in
one transmission the health record sends
back a complete summary of the patients
so far the patient has encounter with
clinician and the clinicians EHR is
updated and the health bank is updated
pretty simple and that the patient can
control it and by the patient having all
the data in one place it makes a club
possible that the patient could purchase
an application that would run against
their data and say well am i at risk of
such and such and should I change my
eating and should i change my exercise
should I change my sleeping answer for
all those yes well but nonetheless the
idea is based on their data because we
know that when recommendations are based
on personal data it means a lot more
than just say well you should wear your
seat belt where your wife's coloma you
should exercise more when they say you
know we've looked at your genetics and
your family history and your prior
problems and you particularly would
benefit by extra sleep or avoiding such
and such or including such and such in
your diet that sort of thing now we'll
come back to the business model but it
has been proposed that we pay providers
for making deposits in the health record
bank and again it depends on the
business model we'll get to that again
so the things that are in favor of
electronic health record banks are that
most records at providers are already
electronic we couldn't say that in 2006
we've already talked about that
consumers have a right to their record
we have standards such as the CDA and
consolidated CDA that work for filling a
health record bank with appropriate data
you don't need a national patient
identifier because if I walk into my
office for my physician and I and they
say where do you want to represent I
just pull out a card they scan it I'm
not talking about uploading it to the
car I just say
scan and there's okay and then I go home
just like from home depot I go and buy
something and I get a paper receipt if I
want and it's in my email when I get
home seven stead of being in my email
it's in my health record bang it could
be that easy that smartphones can help
on that and we'll talk about computer
security on these so again we talked
about the patient depository we have to
be ready for immediate access for
real-time care we need to prevent the
loss of all the data from an intrusion i
mean anthem with some 80 million records
laws we can have that we're talking
about real healthcare data and then we
also need to make sure that these data
stores allow themselves to be used for
medical research if the consumer so
wishes so specifically getting into
security and then we'll get into
searching but talking about security now
we don't want to jeopardize all the
patient data by a loss of a single
decryption key a loss of a given
credentials any single file that a
person may have or that the searcher
gets access to all the data so those are
security requirements and that we
believe that in that it's been
established a long time ago this is from
a study in 1976 @ centralized data are
more secure and that you don't have much
multiple transmissions as you do with
distributed data but the challenge with
centralized records is they have all the
data in one place and so one break-in
can potentially get to lots of data and
we don't want that so there's this
perception that data in the cloud are
not secure and that is one of the
challenges for all kinds of performance
that we have in our society but
particularly for health records act so
the idea that has been proposed and
there are other ideas that the idea of
storing each patient's record in a
separate place where you still need to
passwords so that you don't get 12
passwords to all the database I mean a
public-private encryption key you don't
get that key doesn't get you access to
all the records that get you access to
one record and the idea and this here
now we're dealing with a different part
about financial bank the security
deposit if you've ever stored stuff in
there you bring your key in from home
and
someone from the bank comes in and they
both unlock it and then they leave you
in in the room to count your gold but
the idea here is that each patient's
record would be under separate patient
password and the system password and
that if you designate a clinician take
care of room care of you and look at
your record that you would give her of
access to your key she would know what
your key is but she gets her key through
your key and a listed cap and then when
you leave that position you would draw
her access to your record and she loses
her key to your record so that's the
idea of storing it all in one place but
under individual password so this has
written up in journal biomedical
informatics he goes through it in detail
so the idea is that each patient's
records stored in a separate location
although all essentially the challenge
is that when you do searching for
research it can take a little longer and
will address that so the idea that he
wanted to show that dr. jasna polana to
show is that searching isn't a big
problem and here's why so if you have
one record and you're just looking for
one record it you retrieve the record
you decrypt it you examine it and then
you go on to the next record and if
you've done all and records you exit and
you're done so I'll take n iterations
but if if you have two processors then
you do it parallel and then the time it
takes is n over 2 and then of course you
get the idea that if you have K
processes which is a common way to do
computing now that you have n over K and
that in a cloud environments wouldn't be
an inconceivable have a thousand or ten
thousand processors to do searches
across 10 or 30 million people so what
he did there was to take a look at again
simulated along the x-axis you have the
number of parallel search server is
going from 250 to 10,000 these are
commodity servers and then along the z
axis you have the population involved
and then the variable is or the
dependent variables how long does it
take to produce a search record where
you do
a search speed of 25 records per second
you can see that with 5 even 10 million
patients in there that at 25 records for
second searching that you're still out
at 30 minutes or so which is pretty
reasonable for research this is search
is not for when you're getting care
there has to be immediate active
searches when you're doing research and
you can afford to wait a little bit of
time so what we're doing is trading off
the security of having a single person's
record under a single password versus
taking a little longer to do the search
and then on this slide he adjust and now
what we've said is let's fix the
population to 10,000 and say what is the
effect of speed on the outcome and you
can see that if you can do 50 records
per second you can even do 10 million
with the less than 10 minutes recovery
time so the point is is that this
exceeds to a widespread commodity search
with multiple servers so we balanced the
security of individual record under
single password versus ability to search
all the records using distributed
processing so just got a couple slides
looking over the comparison of health
information exchanges with health record
banks so we've already talked about
health information exchanges as are many
to many scattered distribution health
record bank you get it all in one place
send it to one place many-to-one to send
it and then all 121 to retrieve it for
that visit well with hie you have many
records coming in at the same time you
have to manage that and reconcile them
with health record bank it's already
been reconciled that our job at the
health record bank is to make the
deposits as they come reconcile it with
the records are already in place and
then you get one summarized record at
the time of care now if you have health
information exchanges without a
repository you have no place for the
patients are result put together but a
health record bank the very essence of
it is that all the patients deposits are
in one place with health information
where I talked about you need a lot of
trusted stakeholders to come together
make agreements with a health record
bank once it's established and once the
patient gives it the trust and once
they should go to their providing that
would you send me a copy then you you're
beyond having have multiple stakeholders
degree on it health information
exchanges are viewed by some as being
the providers record clearly with the
health record bank gets a consumers copy
of their professional health record and
they own it they get decide where to put
it then you have genomic and imaging
data again more kinds of healthcare data
they're scattered all over and
especially with with genomics you're
going to want them under your control
and be able to add to it and if you want
to get one more panel to add two years
and do it all it's in terms of even a
retail process meaning not for necessary
for clinical care you're going to want
to store it with the rest of your data
because interpreting those genomics make
sense only in the sense of all the other
habits and all the other history that
you have now when a consumer moves with
a health information exchange they may
have a way to send the data but
especially if it's scattered data they
don't have a central repository it's
going to be hard for them update whereas
moving with the health record bank it's
not an issue in the same way that even
if your bank doesn't have a retail
location as a small town that you move
to you can still do your banking with
that original bank nothing changes we've
talked about consumers choosing apps on
time on a mobile app or a whole math but
probably a mobile app to run against
their data hard to do against hie where
you don't really own the data you don't
really have the data under your
management but easy to do with a health
record bank if there's an error you
corrected in your health record bank and
then the next person that goes to look
at it is that you're going to see for
care gets the updated copy easy for
consumers to control access and then
again as we get to patient generated
help it easier to do with your to your
own records and to do it to all the
providers that you might see but there
are problems with a centralized model
who's the data stored who governs access
who controlled access individual records
who controls search so we have health
record Bank Alliance proposes that
communities get together with a
non-profit board of consumers and
providers to say what are the rules from
managing this health record bank you can
have a private party for
of an organization actually doing the
storage but we would propose that
because these are sensitive that the
initial health record banks be managed
by community groups who get together and
they set the rules and then they hire
out the actual technical storage of
their data another problem with
centralized accesses we have a single
point of failure so if a health of bank
of help us health record bank loses
their internet connectivity because of a
DNS attack then you're you're without
and that's a problem that we haven't
allowed to figure out ways it is to have
copies of your data in multiple places
so that one out each may not affect it
so severely and we talked about risk of
the whole data set being compromised ok
this is a proposed business model a
health record bank according to these
data haven't been put together yet but
the idea is well what is it what does it
work through what's it look like
financially so this is based on many
spreadsheets putting together how many
technical people does it take to manage
incoming data to reconcile it to manage
the storage that sort of thing so at a
million subscribers they're figuring
that their cost of sixteen dollars per
person per year but look at that there's
six dollars to manage the storage and
ten dollars per person ear to pay
providers to create deposits so if we if
we take that out we're talking at six
for six dollars per person for a million
six million dollars about the cost of
most health information exchanges right
now now in terms of revenue sponsorships
meaning that people that will pay
because they believe that they can offer
an application to the patient that the
patient will want and so they may
sponsor the data applications this would
be paid for by consumers for example the
emergency department access alert means
what happens if I fall off my bike show
up at the emergency department to see
Andy he doesn't know who I am or knows
who I am but I know my record that burn
see dogs get automatic access to health
record bank and everybody my family and
friends co
gets the email it says hey Gibson showed
up in the emergency department emergency
doctor they are open the record meaning
that there's the break the glass access
they have good access to my full records
and there will be a price to pay if
that's inappropriate and meanwhile my
family knows that that doctor looked at
preventive care reminders are things
that we believe that patients will pay
for to help them manage their care
medication reminders again you can do
preventive care reminders and medication
reminders without your health record
bank but these are just examples of
applications that could run against all
of your data in one place research is a
big deal but I don't know what the value
of our data are but I would think that
if you had a million people I in a given
area with their complete data and half
of them say yeah you can use my data for
research inappropriately identified or
in a de-identified way and oh by the way
is in a pay me for that that it could be
pretty valuable saying what is the
effectiveness of drugs out in the
marketplace when they're being used so
this does not assume any health care
cost savings so about health insurance
company said this could be helpful for
managing populations that they might pay
for some of the health record bank the
freemium model means that you get basic
applications you get your records no
charge to you and that you can buy up if
you want some of these other
applications and then there could be
advertising or you could buy out the
advertising by by paying for it in the
same way your kindle cheaper if you take
the advertising it's thirty dollars more
if you take your kindle with without
advertising just some ideas and so
running that business model through
ultimately getting at 2 million 2.8
million consumers by month 48 break-even
was at 16 months and substantial return
on investment of in the third and fourth
years again these are just models based
on number of people they felt would be
necessary to run a health record bank
for three million people so it was tried
in arizona 2010 2011 and it fails and i
got to give credit to Billy a snob Ted
short left is is the
it's a chair of the board of health
record banking alliance in a long term
proponent of it he actually lived as
part of a year in Arizona and they wrote
up that they fail doing a health record
bank in Arizona 2010 I remember 2010
high-tech American Recovery and
Reinvestment Act was just getting
started electronic health records were
not in as whitey use as they are now
nonetheless they start out with four
hundred thousand dollars capitalization
they had a community nonprofit that did
the governance and set the rules and
then they paid a for-profit health
record Bank company to do the technical
piece they did initially billboard and
radio and then they went to Facebook and
Twitter and they got some uptake by
consumers they also went to large
physician groups and did in person
marketing and the physicians were
signing up to get paid for making the
positive stealth record Bank of course
in the early months and years that's not
a lot of payment but over time the idea
that physicians at scale would get three
or dollars per month for contributing
data to health record bank and this is
not onerous you just say you use your
same EHR interface you just put a new
address in it as you would with direct
they were also looking at initially a
ninety nine dollar fee to consumers they
did surveys and they they can they
survey consumers and consumers that I
pay between 100 and 150 dollars to start
this process and that about twenty five
or thirty percent of people said that
they would be willing to pay at that
level for this so again that's well less
than seventy-five percent will less than
a hundred percent but people will know
pay some they start out ninety nine
dollars what they turned out they only
got ten consumers to sign up so it
failed and one of the things in going
back is physicians were reluctant to ask
patients to pay for something that's
going to cost them money directly so our
feeling going forward is we don't charge
the patient because that's a non-starter
one of our one of our challenges is that
we don't believe that patients really
care about their records until they get
sick or until it family member gets sick
or injured
I'm sorry under the question was until
somebody asked for sure so we don't care
until someone asked for it and then we
wish that we had it oh I have a friend
who I went to high school with college
with we went to different medical
schools he was an anesthesiologist he
had pneumothoraces I had pneumothoraces
and he was in Hawaii he had his lung
scrubbed from it but it could always
come back he thought he was getting it
on a weekend you think I'm going to go
to kawaii urgent care now I'm going to
have this complicated history about new
authority so he was scrambling why he
was having chest pain scrambling to put
his records together so that when he
appeared in urgent carry data records
well again as you point out until you
need it until someone asks for it you
don't care about it but then you do care
about it all in a hurry so we believe
that the idea is make this so simple
using existing standards that is sort of
like would you like a copy of today's
visit sent so you just do it
automatically yeah it just collects
there and then when you need it you know
I've already got that covered doesn't
cost me anything and we're ready to go
so what a policy changes do we believe
are needed to make health record banks
work I counted to number one is you got
to require clinicians to do what HIPAA
and 21st century cures already require
which is send it but instead of making
it when the patient asks just make it
routine now will that be politically
public feasible well this is the
challenge of my job and of this concept
of can we convince them to put in an
apology saying you need to send it it's
not it's obligated now now I talked to
Western of the quality health network in
Grand Junction Colorado and there are
health information exchange with a
federated model but he says that even
though it's a federated model which each
organization maintains their own data
when you make a query it acts like it's
centralized it's that fast and I said
well do you have a patient portal and
says you know we did but then our and
they have here's an example one of the
successful health information exchanges
western Colorado 150,000 patients 1,100
providers 130 offices 26 hospitals
70,000 queries per month the database
so there and they have ninety-four
percent participation among their
providers that's the sort of
participation needed to make all this
work so i would say they've got what
they need in quality health network for
real-time care research is another thing
patient controls another thing but if we
overlap if we overlap health information
exchanges with the repository with
repository and a health record bank I
think there's a big overlap but the idea
is because you have a patient portal on
he says well we wanted that but then the
doctors screen because they get
meaningful use dollars by showing that
they have five percent of their patients
actually using that if the patients are
going to the hie portal instead of the
individual office coral they lose their
credit for Meaningful Use so they had to
turn it off so again that that's a
change that we need to make in the in
the requirements to make sure that that
worked all right so we need to relax it
in that case but it's our contention we
don't need new standards for all the
information they're not perfect but
they're good enough to get going even if
we have text blobs coming over for
family history maybe we can do natural
language processing to pre digest it for
clinicians that's another talk we'll do
that another day but the idea is let's
just get a copy of what's being
collected anyway sent to the patient
under their control so we've already
talked about the challenge some of the
challenge most consumers probably don't
care about their health care records
there's an argument about whether
boomers care more about whether
Millennials care more we can have that
discussion I would say that most
clinicians don't know that the patient
gets a copy it's a full electronic copy
if they ask for it they're pretty much
used to putting their portal up there
and saying that that's good I think one
of the doubt one of the headwinds reruns
with the health record bank is that
there have been a lot invested in state
health information exchanges and for
people to say you know we're going to
augment that that requires I just think
its growth but other people would
perceive that as a failure and I think
that's the reason why they
go along with health record bank we'll
see what the new administration the new
Congress and does I believe that some
vendors believe that they are going to
offer that personal health record with a
woman's name to their patients but i
think that there's reasons to do it away
from electronic health record vendors
but they may want to do that I'd be
buying if one of the epic Cerner
allscripts meditech wanted to do a
consumer record and we put up the
characteristics and evaluate and say
does it meet our principles of what we
want with health record by insurance
companies may feel some loss of power on
one hand made me feel lots of power that
somebody else is collecting data like
the patient that might be more powerful
the other point if once you move to
value-based payment and may say hey if I
can get all the clinical data and the
payment data and we engage the patients
in their care maybe they can become less
expensive to manage and will do better
and maybe accountable care organizations
would be interested in this of course as
with banking we had a hundred years to
set up banking regulations but there
needs to be audit and it needs to be
regulation but that's not inconceivable
that could happen and then genomics and
imaging data those kind of costs that I
add there weren't looking for storage
costs where you have genomics and
imaging data especially imaging data but
I think storage costs will continue to
come down I don't see that as it made a
big a big hill to get over but it is a
consideration so who should hold sales
record bank government I'm not sure that
most consumers are going to be happy
with the government hosting that
insurance companies I think consumers
feel a certain distrust with some
insurance some parts of some insurance
companies hospitals I think have
competitive issues they're not ideal
physicians are working hard just to get
to carry down I'm not sure they haven't
wherewithal to do this accountable
occurring rescission they could do this
especially when the value of all the
data becomes clear when you truly go at
value-based care and we're not there yet
financial banks I don't want throw that
out I think that there are banks that
are doing medical banking that's a
different content from health record
banking medical banking is where banks
you
the inexpensive technology manage the
copay and the point of service
collection in the deductible and all
that and cerner ran a medical bank for
their employees that made it very easy
the whole thing was reconciled all the
transaction taken care of as in the
patient presented for care and then
community organization we've talked
about because if we could get a place
like Portland OR Oregon to say just send
a copy of what you're sending to each
other send it to a health record bank
Portland be a great place to do this so
my last content slide then we'll go to
questions is blockchain what about
watching lots of hype about watching
Harvard Business Review just had to
write up just a couple weeks ago in a
January edition about watching I think
they got it right I think that blunt I
mean I don't think watching is a
distributed ledger mean it's a great
place to say here's what happened here's
a transaction having a certain date time
and things where we count on somebody
else like a county government to store
who bought houses who recorded their
title to a house so you don't get at
them adverse claims on your house title
or identities who now we count on the
state to do driver's license but the
idea was wandering great place to store
where no one person is in charge of
facts and transactions but I would say
it's not a good place to store the
content of medical records it's a good
place to store not a patient was seen by
a given provider on a different given
date time and then some doctor in New
York contribute says I saw Gibson in New
York when he was visiting in April 29th
and April 30 sight throughout and for
some reason I had to see Andy the
moonscape arm around a bad year on April
thirtieth and that Andy's the emergency
department records it in Portland the
other burns department recorded in New
York ultimately the block chain nodes
are brought up to speed and then the
next person on Monday April or May first
would see exactly what order was and
they know where to go for my record not
required trail traffic bank but I think
that the idea is that blotching is not a
place to store records there might be a
pointer to your records so
that it it's too expensive and too
complex to store the content of the
record but it may have something to do
with keeping a secure agreed upon record
uncontroverted will record of who saw
boom when okay in summary we've talked
about health record banks and their data
are required for safe care and
population health management we don't
need anymore standards to do it hippo re
says that per view download and transmit
and I went and looked at it a lot this
week to make sure it says view download
and transmit to our portal that doesn't
transmit it's not adequate to meet the
letters wall with HIPAA Lord 21st
century cures if the patient has four
well I think helped record banks have a
lot of the value of health information
exchanges but add even more in terms of
patient control the ability to upload
your own data the ability to control of
the auditing the sense of privacy over
your record and we talked about about HR
BS don't exist in that name yet in this
country although I'm trying to establish
contact with health information
exchanges that are run a lot in the same
way I think rhode island has one I think
my health of my health place in aqua
Florida has that quality health network
and western Colorado may have a lot of
that and that there's also not yet
confirmed health record business model
but I think that they have a chance of
being sustainable based on their value
to consumers and the applications and
research that will pay for health record
so let's all we have time for some
questions and love to hear what you're
thinking thank you here so since I'm
sitting in for bill today I'll ask the
first question because fill out these
guys this is great really fascinating
stuff I have a couple of questions a lot
a couple of areas that seem like they're
their substantial challenges yeah one is
that it sort of seems like it's
screaming for some kind of inexpensive
killer app in this space that you bring
the consumer in with the freemium model
but you're really dependent on a
significant fraction of consumers being
willing to pay for the updated app and
what might that be and is there data
backing up what that would be in the
second the second question and maybe
maybe I just didn't see it the way what
you talked about it does seem like
there's some complexity with a lot of
health providers having arrangements
with the health record bank in order to
you know be assured of the HIPAA
compliance and the financials and all
that so while it may be less complex
than than a health information exchange
in all the n-by-n kind of things it does
seem like you know a health record Bank
of Oregon and Washington having
relationships with all the health
providers in Oregon Washington seems a
daunting task but maybe you could talk a
little bit more about that no I think it
is a daunting task I think we're deep in
the end zone now I do believe that
things are better now than they were ten
years ago in terms of the killer app I
don't think we know what that is yet i
spoke with john casillas on tuesday he
established the medical banking project
he promotes out all over the world and
that's medical banking where you're
handling micro payments and payments for
healthcare we talked about he agrees the
challenge is finding that application
that will make all this payoff you know
I don't exactly at their there's a
company called daca do that does a
health score and they take an enormous
history I started it but it takes a take
some time to complete where they ask you
about all your habits and everything
that's happened to you ask you about
your numbers a blood pressure
cholesterol which your exercise what
kind of exercise you should do is stress
level your status of your relationship
pretty personal information and then
they give you a score between zero and
thousands and it changes day to day and
then of course for those that are
competitive I'm not in that sense but
for those that are competitive now
they're doing rollator their buds about
whether the score is going
up and down at they sleep more to this
quarter anyway I'm not saying that to
kill around but it's intriguing because
it's based about me and what happened to
me and in fact what I do in the past and
what do I appear to be at risk at I'd
also say as those genomic markers come
in one by one over time now we're going
to over find out things I mean all these
things that you thought like white can
some people smell in their urine that
asparagus and other people well I don't
know exactly what number but they found
the gene for that or or why is it that
the end we can eat so much fat and I
mean the several genes that I mean all
these things that we y can tell my wife
hate some spices that her whole family
hates what's the one in Mexican food
starts with the scene cilantro she hates
on for me I don't really taste it that
much but her whole family brothers
sisters all of them I'm sure there's a
gene for an out cilantro is
insignificant but as the genomics come
in and combined with our habits and our
current functioning I think that will be
valuable is it a killer app demarco out
to tell and I don't know the answer that
in terms of the complexity about
building yeah it's complex but it's not
like we have to start over with the
standards we just it's already in the
law that it's required I think that we
need to get a demonstration side up and
the idea openly would be we might start
with a community but I think ultimately
you might look to a national
organization like the visa did with with
credit card payments is that yeah you're
part of the visa network and you just
send it there rule ferreted out not not
fair will move your data out to the
particular bank that yours but you just
upload when you do your visit in
addition of paying for it you also just
upload your record to the health bank
that you have an account with and you go
online echeck and see events turn well
agree it's a big deal and that's part of
my job is to figure out create awareness
look at what we need to do policy wise
and on the hill and say how are we going
to bring this about so no it's complex
but it's not like we have to make up a
lot of new stuff go ahead so thanks very
much and I
first wanted to say that things like
this like health record banks I think
are going to be incredibly important but
as you mentioned there's a lot of
difficulties with it a couple that I
wanted to ask you about is one is you
know why for example do you think that
it should be a privatized situation and
you know why should we or why do you
think that customer or consumers are
more likely to trust a private in this
organization or a private company to
hold all of this data more so than they
would dress for example a local or
federal government to I wanted to
highlight one possibility in terms of
like you're bringing up killer apps or
reasons that consumers would do this
because it seems like a big hurdle is
how do you get people to actually be
interested in this whole thing to begin
with and that's you know maybe it should
be monetized for the consumers instead
of being monetized for the company that
is doing all of this in the sense that
consumers already we give up all of our
health data we give up all this
information and companies like insurance
companies and other corporations
actually market are our information out
as you know advertisements or other
health indices or whatever you know this
kind of a project would would definitely
allow consumers essentially take control
of that and then the last thing that I
just want to mention really quick is
health providers already have access so
will prevent health providers from doing
an end run on this process essentially
because HIPAA does give them the right
to access whatever care whatever
information they need about their
patients that involves direct care so
there's nothing that would force them to
go to these things in order to access
information taking a third question
first they go there because over time it
would be more complete and they could go
to one place and get it all so that
that's why they would do even though
they get it where ever they would i
SPECT these hie s will continue
especially the vendor Beiste cherries
will continue the second one in terms of
monetizing absolutely we believe that
the monetization data will be very
valuable and I just don't know what the
dollar amount of that is but no the in
the consumer would have the right to
make that decision so different from
where your data taken out you're not
involved this would have to be expressly
saying you get to choose here's the
value equation here's the day they're
going to use in here is how much you can
pay for it so we think motivations a big
deal it will capitalize it to begin with
because of the network effect but over
the long term on ization porn and the
next one up for the next iteration is
talk I will research the surveys on who
consume consumers trust and I just
proffered that they're more likely to
trust a trusted private organization
than government but I'm just property
not now based on my experience but I
don't have the data and all will work
that up so how about you and then you
you
we believe regions and communities are
the best absolutely that's the place
care is mostly regional this idea that
I'm in New York and I get hurt or
something that's less than 1% of it or
even less than that so no we totally
agree its community based its regional
base and that's where we would start
that's a place to show it the long run
it could be national but no we agree it
starts with it starts with the community
and that's where we build the critical
mass rural yeah I mean you could see
that Eastern Oregon with a few hospitals
over there and the multiple providers
they could still benefit but you're
right I urban areas may benefit the most
of that but it's a model that I mean we
look at ed AE emergency department
information exchange and pre manage and
how that's taken off and all the
hospitals in Washington Oregon do that I
mean you can see what community can do
and if it the city is that the state is
it to States getting together either the
antimatter so okay so does that mean we
can start at your in Portland one more
question I think we have time for thank
you
yep
you
okay let's stay in touch on that oh I in
terms of putting all this together I
think it's an issue of trust and it
makes a lot of sense what you say and
the issue is again me I need to bring
myself up to speed on what consumer
sentiment is on this but I think it's an
issue of trust whether we could put all
those data parts together
what
right agree that's a challenge if it'll
do it at their clinician physician
advises up to I mean it goes way up now
maybe that's weak you know thank you
very much for the attention thanks for
the ideas